so yeah it's great to be here my name is
Patrick and I'm one of the co-founders
of research Hub and today I'm here to
talk about the incentive structure of
academic science and how dii or
decentralized science can help to fix it
so first all a little background about
me um I've had the privilege of dropping
out of not one but two academic science
institutions the first was a PhD program
in wer biology at Boston University and
the second was medical school at
Georgetown
um there was a common theme between all
of my experiences in both basic science
research and applied medical research
it's that there are centralized
institutions that unintentionally
sponsor bad behaviors by creating
perverse incentives for instance
consider the culture of publish or
perish as a scientist it's imperative
that you not only publish often but that
your Publications generate a lot of
citations this is because there are
funding bodies who essentially allocate
Capital based on on researchers prior
publication history in theory this makes
sense right like if you have money and
you want to give it to science you want
to give it to someone who's demonstrated
the ability to do good work in the past
but in practice highly cited papers
don't always necessarily equate with
good work in fact meta scientists have
found that the more often a paper is
cited actually it's less likely to
reproduce in the future and scientists
generally don't want to produce like
kind of like incremental small finding
because they're less likely to be cited
and make them less likely to gain
funding in the future the downstream
effects of this is a tremendous amount
of waste people have estimated that
between 50 to 85% of all science is
irreproducible which is essentially just
money down the drain and as you can see
it's a lot of
money so what are we building at
research Hub to try and fix this we're
kind of taking two approaches the first
is to build an online native tool that
allows anyone to publish scientific
research in the open
the second is creating incentives for
healthy research behaviors as you can
see here we kind of have a Reddit style
Forum where anyone can earn the erc20
token research coin for sharing papers
publishing directly to our Forum openly
commenting on these papers and doing
peer reviews we also have some tools
that allow for collaborative uh writing
of scientific papers this is an
electronic lab notebook that allows
anyone to work together uh with their
colleagues around the world world and
published directly to our Forum it's
kind of like a notion editor for science
we also have a reference manager we just
shipped which allows scientists to save
the papers they're most interested in
and then annotate them as you can see
here we have one of our immunologists
Cole who's using our reference manager
to leave inline CIT or inline comments
that become a peerreview on Research
up.com when you shared content that's
been highly upvoted you earn research
coin and what can you do with research
coin you can create incentives for other
scientists so for instance say you just
shared a pre-print and you'd like a peer
review rather than paying a journal an
article processing charge you can take
the research coin you've already earned
and create a bounty for another
researcher to come in and share a peer
review there are lots of ways people are
using bounties right now for instance we
have a neuroscientist who is trying a
new protocol in their lab they kind of
got stuck and they came to research Hub
to try and get unstuck they created a
bounty for an expert to come and
troubleshoot their protocol and they
ended up moving forward in their own
experiments in their own PhD
career one of the examples that I'm most
proud of and I think illustrates what
we're trying to do here at research Hub
is um if anybody remembers a couple
months ago in Mexican Congress there
were aliens that were presented to the
world kind of fortunately the people who
presented these aliens actually took a
DNA sample and submitted it to ncbi so
on Research Hub we have community
members who are interested in this and
we're like hey let's figure out what's
going on here so they got together used
our electronic lab notebook and created
a post attached a bounty to it for
someone to come in and actually analyze
the DNA that was shared on
ncbi spoiler alert unlikely to be aliens
unfortunately we had a bioinformaticist
within 24 hours of the bounty being
created that came in did some analytics
and found that there was a lot of UK
carotic some procaryotic DNA and some
unidentified DNA um so yeah this is kind
of like a small small example of what
can potentially happen at scale with
research
Hub so I want to leave everybody with
one of my favorite quotes um from Aaron
Schwarz the founder of
Reddit thank you very much for your
time